Sebastian Lege stellt streichzarte
Butter her und demonstriert, wie viel
Butter nach der Verdünnung mit Joghurt,
Wasser und Pflanzenöl noch übrig bleibt.
Ein Fall für den Lebensmitteldetektiv.
Man holt morgens das Päckchen aus dem
Kühlschrank, man beschmiert sich das
Brot und zack, man hat Butter. Aber - Butter?
Auffällig: Das Wort Butter ist im
Produktnamen nicht enthalten.
Stattdessen klingende Namen wie "Streichgut", "Botterram" und "Streichfein".
Es darf noch nicht einmal mehr Butter genannt
werden, sondern nur streichzarte
Kreation mit einem Hauch von Butter.
Mithilfe einer selbst gebauten Apparatur
will der Produktentwickler zeigen, wie
solche streichzarten Butteralternativen
hergestellt werden.
Fertig ist unsere Misch-Streichfett
-Maschine für den lukrativen Butter-
genuss. Lukrativ für die Hersteller, denn
die sparen an der teuren Hauptzutat - der
Butter. Sebastian nutzt für seine Version
gerade so viel, dass der typische
Buttergeschmack erhalten bleibt. Joghurt
dagegen ist recht preiswert. Joghurt gibt eine
schöne Frische, hat auch viel Wasser. Joghurt gibt nicht nur Geschmack, er sorgt auch
für ordentlich Volumen.
Die Butter ist schon mal richtig schön
aufgeschlagen, jetzt pumpen wir das ganze
noch mal schön auf mit allem anderen
außer Butter. Mehr Fett, bessere
Streichfähigkeit - dafür sorgt in Leges
Mix Rapsöl, das kostet gerade mal ein
Fünftel von Milchfett. Doch damit nicht
genug. Jetzt wird's richtig günstig, ein ordentlicher
Schluck Wasser.
Echte Butter darf höchstens 16 Prozent
Wasser enthalten,
doch bei Streichfett-Kreationen gibt es
keine solchen Limits. Sebastian Lege
zeigt, wie viel Wasser da reinpasst.
Ein Emulgatorpulver sorgt dafür, dass
sich alles verbindet.
Fertig ist unser Volumenwunder. Wollen wir
mal sehen, was ich so aus vier Stücken
Butter rausgeholt habe. Butter darf der
Produktentwickler seine Kreation jetzt
nicht mehr nennen.
Formal handelt es sich um ein
sogenanntes Mischstreichfett.
Aus vier Stücken Butter habe ich jetzt 2, 4, 6, 7
Schalen Mischstreichfett mit
Buttergeschmack gezaubert. Das nenne ich
mal 'nen pfiffigen Trick der
Lebensmittelindustrie. Pfiffig vor allem
mit Blick auf die Gewinnspanne,
denn die streichzarten Alternativen
enthalten günstigere Zutaten als Butter,
kosten im Geschäft aber fast das gleiche.
Der Preisunterschied beträgt gerade mal
20 Cent.
Egal ob bei Marke oder No-Name
Produkten.
Noch dreister langt die Industrie bei
den Light-Varianten hin.
Sie sind nicht nur streichfähig, sondern
auch noch kalorienarm. Während in
herkömmlichen Mischprodukten noch rund
60% Öle und Fette stecken, enthalten
Light-Varianten noch weniger von den
teuren Zutaten. Solche Produkte bestehen
oft mehr als zur Hälfte aus Wasser.
Erkennen kann man das an der Hauptzutat, die muss ganz oben stehen.
Hier ist eine
ganz pfiffige Variante - Wasser als erste
Zutat. Da war ein Kollege dran, der hat's
richtig drauf.
Für das Ding hat er bestimmt einen Orden bekommen.
Der Brotaufstrich wirbt zwar mit
Buttergeschmack, doch drin steckt gar
keine mehr, lediglich Pflanzenfett. Erst das Aroma
sorgt für den Buttergeschmack. Für den
Verbraucher bedeutet es, wenn meine
Butter oder meine mein Mischstreichfett viel
Wasser enthält, bezahle ich natürlich für
Wasser und nicht für Butter. Wenn ich
Kalorien sparen möchte, reicht es in der
Regel, die Butter dünner aufs Brot zu
streichen, aber es muss kein Light-Produkt
sein, denn das ist in der Regel auch
genauso teuer wie Butter. Unserem Wunsch
nach streichzarter Butter ist die Industrie
nachgekommen -
allerdings mit Produkten, die in vielen
Fällen mit Butter kaum noch etwas zu tun
haben.
Für uns eine Erleichterung, für andere
richtig lukratives Geschäft. Wer nicht
auf die streichzarte Variante am Morgen
verzichten möchte, der schaut am besten
nach, wo in der Zutatenliste die Butter
auftaucht. Je weiter vorne, desto besser.
Was kommt bei euch aufs Brot?
Herkömmliche Butter, Streichfett oder
Margarine? Sagt es uns in den Kommentaren.
Und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer Essen
wissen wollt, dann abonniert die ZDFbesseresser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei Clips.